Hey
[Music]
thank you for choosing the stars diner
where every day you're the star did you
guys change your menu yeah I don't
really understand this menu new and
improved menu tell me what what looks
good a side of gluten we offer for you
you guys all got pancakes I'm always on
a diet
so I like the hundred calorie hamburger
you're gonna find needs like 20 to get
filled up they're about the size of a
grape yeah I don't I don't I don't care
that's fine cool so paleo burger yeah
we'll do that that's a road trip burger
right there yeah we'll share that but as
a pun I don't want to buy usually I'll
get a veggie burger perhaps you'd be
interested in our vegetarian option it
has veggies like lettuce does it have
other vegetables on it no uh the nacho
no one needs to know nacho Ultimo and no
one needs them and why would you want
that you don't need to know any specials
the cialis can I interest you in our
signature sandwiches well then what did
you notice our fountain drinks captain
Jake so the El Nino is our special sighs
it's really more of a vat yeah we'll get
that going right now okay so one more
chicken do you like to upgrade to the El
Nino sure
we do have an impulse buy apple pie you
can sit in one of those okay oh I'm
sorry out of the apple pie you guys like
to sign up for our loyalty program no
you just pay five cents now and every
other day we continue to charge you but
when you come in on your 30th I visit
thank you goodbye
thank you I will not be purchasing
please pull up to the first window
okay good ass yes quickly please quickly
please okay no one saw me guys to keep
your money
[Music]
Oh